foreign
good morning welcome to jailcar
um
the record will be done from the video
so everyone please be be careful to
identify yourself and use the
microphones
for seating
representative Broda can sit in for
representative hatch who won't be here
and Senator gray for Senator Whitley
uh and Senator fellows and hack and
okay
the minutes of the previous meeting
move to approve is written and presented
second I guess any comments Corrections
seeing none those in favor
aye those opposed
okay
the consent agenda is there anything
does anyone wish to remove something
from the consent agent
yes representative lamb uh thank you
madam chair um if I had a question about
whether the ell definition would impact
school funding would that be something
that we pull or is that just a
an over anxious question
what a good question which uh
which definition is it which um that is
on the third one on the agenda FP uh
2023-23
yes
that's the uh esol teacher correct
I can't believe that would affect
that's about the qualifications for a
teacher
and it defines English language learner
as long as that's an entirely separate
section which not in which would not
impact school money I have no objection
to consent but I wanted to raise the
question ah
you're from
um this um
what is this doing it's relative to the
licensure standard of an esol teacher
um and changes were proposed by the
Professional Standards Board
so it's all about their licensing the
question is does the definition of an
English English language learner
differ in any way from the definition
that is used for school funding
um I'm unsure I'd have to
pull it back up
if the agency is here
I'm sorry if the agency is here then
perhaps they could answer the question
yes is there someone who can answer that
question
turn your background please
there you go leave the light on
I know it went off when you hit it again
so it's supposed to be red okay
um good morning Julie Shea
administrative rules coordinator for the
Department of Education
um that definition did not change from
the last proposal and so I would imagine
that it's not going to affect anything
because
it was already there before
if that makes sense
um the the changes that were made to the
proposal for the esol teacher did not
involve the definitions
and they were already there
from the draft from
the prior rules it did change where OLS
made some comments regarding how the
definitions were written because
um the way that we had it separated out
wasn't in the proper format
and then if that doesn't impact the
funding definition then I have no
problem with consent I just wanted to
clarify that that does not expand the
definition for funding that I I don't
know all I can speak to is what was
there before and that I I don't think it
had any impact prior
um I can either follow up or I can ask
the division director who is down the
street
then perhaps I should pull that from
consent okay we will pull that second
sent you will contact the division
director to make sure there's no impact
all right any other questions on the
consent agenda um is 2023 100 still on
the consent agenda if so I would like to
pull that
it is uh the item v and the consent
calendar
Item B is a V C is in Vector oh Victor
thank you I hadn't gone that far
uh yes okay I'd like to pull that from
consent as well okay
any other uh representative
yeah thank you Mr chair
um
I noticed a grammatical error on of
subsection B which is the charter school
lease Aid
um
page five there's a small grammatical
error so I wasn't sure if that warranted
being removed
director that can be corrected
editorially at the time of adoption
okay
Madam chairman improved consent minus
the items that were pulled second second
okay seconded by you
representative Lynn okay
any further discussion comments or
things to remove
seeing none those in favor
aye those opposed
okay
the first one on the regular agenda is
yes this this rule is no longer
necessary because the office the Allied
health professionals office was
uh deleted in House Bill too so it was
it does not exist
that's correct okay
okay
2023 15 is
um
essentially the issue is that
there's a seal of the board
the board is now using a generic steel
so when
a person
sees the seal it doesn't say that it's
for geologists it's just a generic PLC
board and
um we think that this could could be
confusing if somebody has a seal that
doesn't identify the board it's for and
it's just a generic seal it's a generic
oplc board
um and
I know PLC is going to all generic seals
kind of for everybody but it it may be
confusing if you can't tell which board
it's from
if I could step in here
um so the next proposal also has the
same issue and so the board statutes
actually required the board to adopt an
official seal a design for official seal
so it's unclear it's probably not what
the legislature intended a generic seal
they wanted a specific seal for each
board and so both in 15 and in this one
one for geologists and then the board of
Architects
um like it like Christina said it just
says New Hampshire board councils and
commissions so there's no indication
that it's specific to either geologist
or to Architects and we're seeing this a
lot in the IPS so um so it would be good
to go ahead and figure this out
yes CNN
yeah um from the office of professional
licensure and certification
oplc takes care of all the paperwork of
the boards they process all the licenses
they do all of that
and so that having a seal for each board
um
I don't believe is necessary it says in
the rulemaker story that the board will
have a design design and official seal
they've chosen to go with a generic seal
any documents that are sealed would have
the name of the board on it so I don't
believe it would be confusing as to
which board the documents are from
could you explain how that happens if
you've got a generic seal how does it
say this is a geologist that's it that's
stamping this document no there's two
that's two different things the
geologists who have to seal their their
documents have their own seal that's a
different rule this is the seal that the
board say they had a if if we still
sealed licenses
this would be that seal that would be
used to seal a license like we used to
do I don't believe seals are used
we do
so they're using the generic they're
using the generic seal the document
itself has the name of the board but the
seal the raised seal
representative Corona thank you I just
want to understand make sure that I
understand what you're saying so you're
saying that let's say someone's applying
for a license for
um
structural for architectural
Landscaping
their their license would have a generic
seal that says that
I'm just trying to think of where you
would use this generic seal versus
certifying that the work is being done
by someone who's certified
I can answer that question Lindsay
Courtney executive director oplc so the
seals are rarely used at this point
um since we have moved away from a paper
process they're mostly used for wall
certificates when people request them
and we do we do use seals for wall
certificates
um upon request the whole purpose of
this seal is really to just designate
that it's an official state of New
Hampshire seal and that's the purpose
and I think a generic steel satisfies uh
the purpose of of the seal requirement
in the statute regarding the other
skills those are entirely different and
would designate you know typically a
license number for that professional the
profession but it's very separate and
distinct from the actual State of New
Hampshire seal
follow up
thank you so what you're saying is that
if somebody asks for a wall certificate
and they're an architectural
landscape architect then they would get
a certificate from oplc that has a
generic seal but it would still say
somewhere on that license
what this profession is correct they
would say State of New Hampshire or this
person authorized to practice as
landscape architect and then
um the seal usually at the bottom right
hand corner I think and if an individual
needs their seal for their work that's
something where do they get that
so typically that's required in a lot of
technical professions
um they get that on their own in
accordance with the regulations
established by the profession all right
thank you very much I'm satisfied
representative
um suppose a board wanted to support the
the board that covers the
I guess we're talking about geologists
wanted to write like a
some kind of official letter
you'd you'd have them write that
under the seal and of oplc
in general it I'm just thinking that
they would want to distinguish them who
that ruling is coming from or or request
or whatever it is
so I'm not aware of an official letter
that a board would be able to write
they'd be able to issue orders they'd be
able to issue declaratory rulings
typically we advise against the boards
from just taking positions that isn't um
that doesn't have a basis in statute
um I suppose if they wanted to designate
our position is that that the seal which
again the purpose is to just make clear
that it's a state of neometrial function
isn't administrative function that falls
within our statute
okay
not clear that I understand that support
suppose there's a
somebody wants to write a letter and
it's part of a
public hearing or something and they're
writing an opinion of the board on
something or I don't know might be a
disciplinary action I don't know if
you're the person you know the oplc
takes disciplinary actions or the board
does
just to just just so there's no
confusion
that whatever that document is is coming
from the board
there is no confusion because typically
there's a header that says you know
State of New Hampshire Board of name
your board
um and then order on blah blah blah just
as I went Court opinions we don't we
don't seal disciplinary documents
um
Senator Gray
um like it or not I believe that they
they have met the the legal requirements
what we've written in the law uh the
objection from staff was whether there
would be confusion we've heard testimony
from the Department that it should not
and will not we are all able to write
legislation in the coming year and I
think we've discussed this enough and
[Music]
seconded by uh Senator Gray
any further discussion
I'd like to say that the distinction
between the board seal and the Seal of
the individual professionals
is very important because that's the
seal that needs to say
what the profession is and who the
person is who's doing the official seal
so I'm glad that was brought up and
clarified
anyone else
okay the motion is to approve the rule
of
those in favor
aye aye opposed
okay thank you very much thank you the
board of Architects that I had no other
issues other than that one okay
excuse me can I ask a question please of
the chair I'll be saying then therefore
we approve the removing of the Seal of
the generic seal
for the boards act stamping of things
like wall licenses yes I this I vote no
okay thank you
let the record reflect that senate
representative grow to voted no on the
geologist's rules Senator Lang
I moved to approve 54.
is there a second
by Senator Ennis
okay seeing none those in favor
aye those opposed
no no all right representative grow to
okay
Public Health Laboratories
so this proposal uh
2023-32 the agency did file a
conditional approval that addressed
all of our substantive comments except
for one and the one remaining really
would need a legislative fix as it has
to do with two conflicting statutes
the agency is authorized to uh
set in administer administ
administrative fines in the statutes
however where that fine money goes
there's a bit of a conflict so RSA 5 151
16a directs the agency to forward those
fines to the state treasury in the
straight State Treasury to put that in
the general fund however the next
statute are say 155 16 B directs the
state treasurer once they receive the
administrative fines and civil penalties
from the agency to put that money in a
separate non-lapsing interest bearing
account so there was a question of
whether the legislative intent was that
there are two different types of
administrative fines that will go into
two different
accounts or if the intent was to have
all of the administrative fines put into
one account but which one it's unclear
so that was the only comment I had with
this particular proposal sounds
interesting
okay good morning for the record my name
is Doreen Shockley I'm the manager of
the Bureau of Licensing and
certification
um we would like to thank OLS attorney
for discovering this inconsistency
um we the legislation for the second
section B was
enacted or effective in 2010 so the
inconsistent language has existed since
2010 after receiving your comment I
consulted with one of our attorneys who
agreed that there is Need for
clarification and therefore we are
already in the process of putting forth
legislation I think it's also worth
noting that the intention was in fact
civil money penalties CMP penalties are
very different than the others and we do
We are following the intention and one
is in the general fund and one is in a
separate non-lapsing recurring
all right so
if I understand you correctly you're
saying you're working with some
legislator to clarify which fines go
where
but you think you want you think you
understand it and have been doing so
correct
thank you madam chair
um my question is about what appears to
be some expansion and scope in the
licensing rules
um in 808
um
0.0102 e it says that this is everybody
who is not covered by this it says all
entities that performed wave testing for
the sole purpose of risk assessment and
which test results are not used for the
diagnosis treatment monitoring or
consideration to provide or continue to
provide treatment of disease the
existing rule only says that are not
used for diagnosis or treatment of
disease and I'm curious where there's
this statutory authority to potentially
greatly expand the regulation under this
rule
good
no
okay
Miss Chocolate I guess I'm not really
sure I understand the question
it the question is
um before there was nothing that
required that a lab that is only doing
risk assessment
um and not providing diagnosis or
treatment of disease but if you say it
monitoring or consideration to provide
treatment that would be any sort of
early Wellness testing where you might
be looking at at not looking at any
level of clinical disease but people
looking to see what their risk factors
are and in order to decide whether or
not it is necessary in order to escalate
to a physician by background as a device
analyst I did some work in laboratory
and Diagnostics so the distinction may
seem minutia to you but I've seen the
application thank you for your question
I'm going to defer to our unit chief of
licensing unit for health facilities
good morning so the exemption was
expanded upon on the recommendation of
the CLIA coordinator CMS because the if
it's risk assessment only and they're
not considering treatment or providing
diagnosis
you know diagnosing opinion than it
would be for health fairs screening
Wellness like when a hospital puts on
you know for employees it's the intent
was to avoid the burden of Licensing for
those type of screenings rather than
treatment and diagnosing do I understand
correctly that this expands the type
type of Laboratories that do not need
licensing rather than the ones that do
so it may exempt some existing
Laboratories from licensure is that
correct
no not a non-existing because a true
laboratory who's performing and testing
results for diagnosing or treatment they
need to be licensed this is you'll often
find fares that are that pop up in their
transient it could be blood pressure it
could be blood sugars it could be
cholesterol and it's finger sticks but
by the definition of a lab if you
produce a result and you're diagnosing
it you need a license and we agree with
that but these fares or screenings
aren't providing that type of service
what they do is they'll provide the
numbers like a blood pressure reading or
a blood sugar cholesterol and they
recommend going to your doctor okay so
as clarification wouldn't that be
consideration that you may need
treatment of disease
that when you have a high blood pressure
reading that they say you should go to
your doctor and find out if you need
care correct
um my concern is that this is not in the
inclusive part this is the one that
rules people out it says that
um if it's not used for consideration to
provide treatment that it is required to
be licensed to be be ruled underneath
the statute
now it's tough because it's a negative
and then it's a negative within there so
yeah I do I see what you're saying for
sure and I think it's just a wording
um the intent is that the results aren't
used for that but if we're wording it
wrong and it's inferring that then we
want to clarify that thank you I think
it would be helpful if we could go to
the original language not used for the
diagnosis or treatment of disease
because that is that that would exclude
all of these screening fairs or other
can you restate how you want that
written I understand it better thank you
yes that way we can have the information
this is in Hep 808.02e
[Music]
um that I would like it stated all
entities that performed wave testing for
the sole purpose of risk assessment and
which test results are not used for the
diagnosis or treatment of disease
semicolon
language we have that right here and we
can send the official language to Olaf
okay thank you that will help any
further comments or ask representative
lamb uh thank you sorry I have another
question here in the area of
non-compliance which is in dot o3c so
right on the same page that is a new
area and I saw that previously in the
similar section it did not include a
requirement for State licensure to
comply with other federal or state
requirements so we we've seen the impact
of some federal requirements that are
just rules or
um that may not have have the full
backing and full strength that this
would then cause a problem where
um where it could bring state
enforcement of federal requirements that
this doesn't spell out that it needs to
be a rule it doesn't need to be a law
but is this a CDC recommendation and I'm
concerned about that scope creep
yeah
could you say that a different way I'm
sorry because we do have the authority
if it is a Federal Regulation but CDC
guidance
we can't enforce guidance is it a record
would that the CDC guidance be a
requirement or no because this is
replacing deficiency and it had the same
definition but this area of
non-compliance adds or other federal or
state requirements and I'm just curious
the implications Madam chair yes I I
think because it said Federal
requirements that would include uh
federal law or federal regulations uh in
the CFR but nothing else okay thank you
that clarification is very helpful so
I'll go through all that question thank
you all right any other questions
comments
okay do we have a motion moved or
approve as edited
second okay that's a conditional
approval
and
um
I'd like to add if that's okay with you
Senator that the department continue to
work for the legislative fix on their
funding issues oh actually I mean there
that I'm sure would that be a
recommendation to be added to the motion
thank you any uh further discussion or
comment
okay the motion is to conditionally
accept the rules with the recommendation
they get legislative fixed
those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much
okay
so the next couple of proposals
um the first issue that's going to be
discussed will
apply to not only 20 23 52 but also to
the three subsequent ones so F through H
and this particular issue as we
discussed last time has to do with the
administrative processing fees versus a
licensing fee so the oplc did submit a
it's amended conditional approval
because their original conditional
approval had just removed a fee from the
Plumber's table in that particular rule
section so this amended conditional
approval they have changed it from
saying application related fees to
application processing and Licensing
fees
in the section title of each different
section and then with regard to the
table itself in the places where it had
said application processing they have
added after that and Licensing
it is our office's opinion that this
doesn't really address the issue that
was brought up which is what is
constitutes a licensing fee versus what
constitutes an application fee as these
are two very different fees one is
refundable as it is a benefit conferred
or a conditional privilege which would
be the granting of the license and when
you look at the board statutes as a
whole it's very clear that these are
benefits because the statutes at least
the ones that we have looked at so far
which primarily are the court reporters
and the recreational therapists State
very clearly that you cannot practice
these professions without a license and
therefore it would be a conditional
privilege for you to
be able to practice because you need
that license
I believe our original recommendation
was to just remove the application fees
and just have them as licensing fees as
the oplc was unable to tell which would
be considered a license fee versus what
would be considered an application fee
for each of these sections and they had
mentioned that they needed these rules
to go forward so to address the issue
for now just call them licensing fees
and then have them go back and
reevaluate what would be considered an
application fee
however it seems that they've just added
licensing to make it clear that there
are two fees but they still have not
separated them
um I yes thank you we
representative Broda and I met with the
oplc on this issue because we agree that
there is in fact a license and a
licensing fee and the
the oplc is unable at this time to
determine how much of the fee is a
application fee
which does exist
versus the licensing fee and that they
will be revising this as they deal with
each individual profession
which was agreeable to us because it
turns out that
requests for refunds of license fees are
not common
the most the most usual case is that
someone
is in the middle of an application and
withdraws it probably because I think
they won't get a license
and
but that can be dealt with
on an individual basis if I could just
jump in um you know since the agency
doesn't know what portion of the fee is
going to be a cost recovery and not you
know for a conditional benefit then it
really would make sense to amend these
rules to indicate only that there are
licensing fees until they know what
portion of that fee is cost recovery in
some cases they can probably identify it
when we get to court reporters I can
point that out for you for the committee
but yeah also to also keep in mind that
there's been a lot of rulemaking over
the last eight to 12 months in which
those rules were approved that say that
application processing fees are
non-refundable and the agency is
including licensing fees that are
refundable within that so they really
need to go back and do some cleanup to
those rules so the agent you know you
may want to ask the agency or get the
agency to commit to amending those rules
that have approved
thank you madam chair members of the
committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director oplc with me as attorney
Douglas osterhout from the office of
professional licensure and certification
I think the issue before the committee
is really quite simple it's whether oplc
has the authority to charge the or
assess the fees that are
um proposed in the PLC 1002s and I think
it's quite clear that we do Under the
newly revised Statute or recodification
of oplc Statute which is 310 5. the
executive director of The Office shall
establish and collect all license
certification and renewal fees as well
as any necessary administrative fees I
know a council for Olas did acknowledge
in the court reporters filings that the
application fees can be considered an
administrative fee so clearly there is
authority to charge the proposed fees
now with respect to the application
versus licensing fee distinction I'm not
sure that there is a distinction and I
think that the materials cited by OLS in
the email that we received that's part
of your package
um really explain that you have to look
at the substance sense of what the fee
is actually doing and not just the
language that's being used we would
actually dispute that any of our fees
are for benefit conferred I don't think
that you get a benefit from having to be
required to actually obtain permission
from the government to perform an
occupation this legislature has stated
in statute that the right to pursue an
occupation is a fundamental right and I
think using the title the prohibition on
using the title of court reporter is
really intended for Consumer Protection
issue to make sure that the public
understands who's licensed and who's not
now when we talk about cost recovery the
materials cited by OLS talk about a cost
recovery a true fee which is not
refundable to be considered a fee the
amount paid to acquire quote a business
license must bear a relationship to and
approximate the expense of issuing the
license and of inspecting and regulating
the business license I think it's clear
that all of Opel suits fees support the
regulation of the profession
particularly now thanks to Senator Lang
and legislature that we have a
non-lapsing fund everything goes to
support the oplc regulation so I guess
in some I I think we have the authority
um I I think all of our fees are cost
recovery it doesn't really matter what
you call it because that's what's
happening
um and uh and I would submit that their
fees are very reasonable in light of the
fact that the majority of the fees have
been in existence for years
and if I may just quickly jump in um it
never was an issue of whether or not
they had the authority it's very clear
that they have the authority to collect
these types of fees we're not arguing
that what we're arguing is
um as director Courtney pointed out we
see there's a distinction between these
fees which the OPC doesn't agree with
um and if that continues to be an issue
and if that is a concern for the
committee then perhaps legislation can
come forward to clarify exactly what
type of fee is what or what was intended
the issue is um like she just said it's
not whether they have the authority they
do they can't assess fees it's what type
of Feed the legislature authorize and
it's pretty clear there are two types of
fees they're administrative or cost
recovery and then there are license fees
and that is for conditional privilege so
um you know in the court reporter
statute it's pretty clear that it is you
you can only practice you can only have
that title if you pay and you have a
license so there is also an application
fee that's listed in the statute but
they are different
I believe the the significant point is
that a license fee is refundable and an
application fee is not and the point the
oplc is making is that the the license
part of the fee is vanishingly small
compared to the cost recovery part of
which they consider an application fee
well they can certainly be transparent
with that in their rules and they're not
doing that now ah thank you yes Senate
representative Lynn yeah I I guess I
have to say I I agree completely with
the oplc here I think we're making this
much more complicated than it needs to
be I mean if the if the
as I understand it correct me if I'm
wrong on this but the legislate first of
all on the issue of a conditional
privilege I mean I I guess I it's not
clear to me what license if if the law
requires you to have a license to do
whatever the business is presumably if
you you can't practice the business
without the license so I'm not sure that
you know trying to
trying to draw distinctions between one
type of license or another makes makes
sense but the other thing I guess I'm
really concerned about is
certainly the legislature if it wanted
to could could
draw distinctions between application
fees and license fees and say that one
is refundable and the other is now I
don't have any question that the
legislature could do that but as I
understand that the legislature hasn't
done that unless there's some particular
statute that I'm you know I'm
overlooking but the legislature hasn't
done that they've just sort of said you
can collect they've they've used
language like you know application
license fees administrative fees those
kind of things Without Really indicating
that they intended to distinguish
between those some of the professions do
I mean each board is different that's
one of the issues we have and some of
them do make distinctions between
application fees and license fees but
that's not all of them by any means
and the other issue is that uh for there
are some professions where the initial
licensure fee is significantly higher
than the renewal fee which indicates
that there's a major application
processing part of it
that needs to be done once but not again
yeah
um historically speaking the committee
and staff have always thought of a fee
for a license for the issuance of a
license is refundable if the license is
not issued where it says an application
fee doesn't talk about a license fee if
it says solely an application fee then
that is uh non-refundable
this situation is a little more
difficult because there are a number of
different statutes with the different
boards some say applications some say
license I I think the office is trying
to
make things clearer and more uniform but
I think you may need statutory changes I
also think there's a little confusion
here in these rules because there's
reference to administrative fees I mean
personally from the history I've seen of
the boards and their statutes an
administrator fee was only intended to
be minor administrative costs like a
licensee loses its wall certificate or
its damage and they want a new one so
there's a ten dollar fee for that in the
past people have been able to get a list
of licensees from a particular board
there may be a fee for processing that I
I think now it seems with these rules
that the
dimensions of administrative fees seems
to be expanding
and throughout these proposals it
indicates that these fees are
non-refundable period and that does
include license fees
okay may I just ask one follow-up
question can I just make sure am I
understand are is there now in some of
these licensing statutes is there
specifically does has the legislature
said these fees are refundable
as a the legislature used that language
in some licensing statute
I'm not certain not that I know of no
and I think that's I think that's the
issue because
I could find No Authority for the
proposition
that license fees are refundable and
application fees are not and I think the
materials cited by OLS support the
proposition and I'm quoting from the
memo when evaluating of Revenue law the
substance controls and not the labels so
this over simplistic distinction between
license fees and application fees
um it really has no bearing on whether
or not it's refundable or not I think
you have to undertake the analysis of
the cost recovery versus conditional
privilege in our position is that
everything that we do is cost recovery
because everything supports the
regulation of the profession now some
may be more towards the application
processing itself versus the regulation
which would include assistance with rule
making assistance with investigative
support and I do think that we can do a
much better job of distinguishing you
know which how much is going to what
type of function that it absolutely we
could do a better job and after we you
know continue to
assess costs and allocate them
um but but I I don't think that uh I
just disagree with with the simplified
distinction between license fees and
application fees
going to say um there is only one other
section representative
thank you
so this year the legislation
of surrounding House Bill 655 was that
oplc was going to have jurisdiction over
setting fees
so I'm I'm thinking that there's no
conflict in any of the board statutes
and that HB 655 as amended
overrode or repealed all the authority
that boards have for setting fees I
believe I've some comments from the
staff on that one
um I just am a little confused actually
I'm not sure how a person
that is reading
this the rules would know what fee is
refundable and what fee is not
refundable
um how would they know that if you don't
tell them
which fees refundable which fee is not
we do it's in the PLC 300s
we State explicitly
that you have to look at the 1002s to
determine what the fee and that the fee
is non-refundable Madam and chair if I
just because that was just a preamble to
what I was going to say you're okay so
if that's the case
then I think that and and the oh and the
reason for doing to for centralizing the
licensing process
whether it be the fees was to give a
more efficient and effective way of
dealing with licensing
and
therefore I think that that warrants an
examination
as to how licenses are processed and
what part of the fee is refundable and
what part is not and I think because
we've brought in this amend this new
statute
I think it takes it requires us because
this is a different way of doing things
it requires us to come up with as
efficient or effective way of handling
licensing or Administration fees and
maybe what we're saying is that because
oplc takes on the burden of
responsibility when it issues are
licensed because it is looking at
different components of the requirements
of these licenses they take the burden
on and therefore that is where the the
main portion of fees are
found
or lie
okay director Morrow uh we have no issue
that the office of professional
licensure and certification has
authority to impose fees that's not a
question the question is what type of
fee is it and do they have authority to
I agree that we need to be more
transparent about this but I'm not sure
that
the oplc is able to do that at this
point in time for all the professions
that are listed in this in this rule it
certainly would be
and for all those reasons I think that
the legislative solution is what we need
to this and it's not going to happen
this year and therefore I move the item
second okay moved by Senator gray
seconded by
Senator line any other comments
questions
I'd like to add a condition that the
oplc continue to work on clarifying
their fees the mission is a condition is
acceptable to my motion
okay
we'll we'll uh
just so you don't get bored and idle
okay I was worried
and does that include the previous
um rules that have been passed that
indicate that all fees are
non-refundable
yes if they look at those rules and
decide that they have
that their first pass was overly broad
then yes they should go back and fix
them if as necessary
director Morrow I assume uh your
addition is either a recommendation or
any other comments questions
all right seeing on the motion is to
prove the rule with the
uh recommendation that the oplc work on
transparency
those in favor
aye opposed no
that was Chamblee I think yeah Senator
Chandler all right thank you
okay
recreational therapists
so we got one big issue out of the way
already but and now another one that I'm
sure the oplc is very happy to talk
about again
um which is the retention policy that we
have brought up before
um so I won't get into what has been
said before what I do want to bring up
is that in looking at HB
655 there was language added in four
places that require the oplc to retain
records in accordance with a retention
policy developed by the agency but it
does not state that it needs to be filed
with the Secretary of State as I know
that was an issue that the Secretary of
State specifically the director of
archives does not have rules with regard
to retention policies and what our
office's concern is is that this affects
the licensees or anyone else who is
looking for these records so it affects
the public at large so it should really
be in rules somewhere to ensure that
this is being
applied uh
even to all people evenly all boards
evenly additionally RSA 541a is the
committee may be aware specifically
states that you know if it is a rule it
needs to be written as a rule
um unless it is specifically exempt in
statute which we do not see an exemption
in the statutes here there is also case
law in New Hampshire that specifically
states that policies are not enforceable
uh
the public cannot enforce the agency
cannot enforce it as it is just an
internal policy as opposed to a rule so
we would once again argue that this
retention policy should be written as a
rule and based on what we're seeing in
HB 655 that the oplc should
probably put those in rules themselves
and therefore would recommend that the
committee consider potentially a
petition for rulemaking regarding this
issue
director Morrow
historically most agencies the boards
have had rules that say for example
the board shall retain records for all
records for three years unless otherwise
established by the director of archives
pursuant to RSA 5 colon 30. where he
does have the he or she does have the
authority to establish requirements
regarding record retention I mean the
director could say
I want all agencies to retain records
for five years it's not necessarily
submitting those records to the director
of archives but at least uh
completing them as was indicated in this
instance there is no uh requirement
for a specific time or how to retain the
records the records are simply being
held pursuant to an outside document
by the agency but if I understand
correctly the issue is that the director
of archives has the authority to write
rules on this and has not yet done so
yes I spoke with the Secretary of State
yesterday morning he indicated a
willingness to meet and talk with that
in fact have a meeting with staff and
oplc if they wish to discuss the issue
but you are absolutely correct that uh
for decades the director of archives has
not had rules on this and if the
committee wished it could petition for
director Lindsay thank you um
for the record Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc
um so this is a carryover language from
what was in 310a that was added I I
believe one or two legislative sessions
ago
and
um interacting it it was purpose we
purposely did not stay and according to
the rules adopted by 541a because we
believe that the rule making Authority
actually lies with the secretary of
state
and so we did follow the process even
though it's not enrolled took us over a
year to get approval from the Secretary
of State
um and we did adopt in a policy what was
approved by the Secretary of State's
office
um and and specifically about archives
so I'm happy to put this into rule but I
do think that that conflicts with their
Authority and I think if there is a
petition for rule making it really
should lie with the secretary of state
and not with the office
okay since you have a document from the
secretary of state that you're using it
incorporate by reference to the guidance
from the Secretary of State because like
that might
it's not their their document it's the
Secretary of State's document
we can make it part of the record for
this rulemaking but it it's not
something that can be at this point be
included as incorporation by reference
okay
that seems to me that that's
really they're referring to the guidance
they have been given by the agency that
has authority over that area
so I don't think we want the oplc to
make rules on this issue yeah my concern
is that such a letter from the Secretary
of State
telling or
indicating to oplc this is how you
should keep your records well the
keeping of those records by the by oplc
I would say constitutes a rule because
it affects people outside
they may have their own requirements I
mean it should be someplace Incorporated
in a document that everyone can see
Senator thank you so again my concern as
we get into the same problem we had oplc
with boards had rights to make rules and
then the agency had right to make rules
and the rules were conflicting so my
concern is that if the agency adopts
rules that then goes and conflicts with
the archivist rules then we have you
know a constitutional issue which one is
the overriding regulation so I'm not
sure we're talking to the right person
um and that I think it's the archivist
that has the responsibility for setting
the retention rules for the state and
then the agency would be required to
follow that rule for retention so I
think we're kind of yelling at the wrong
person in the short term I think
Courtney uh the director has corrected
it by creating an internal policy until
the rules are adopted and I think
they've followed the right process so
I'm going to make a recommendation to
approve
represent their fellows
um my concern was along the same general
line is um what Senator Lang just said
that that the um
the retention policy is not
necessarily driven just by what the
archivist says it has to do with I think
it needs to have to do with like what
the material that you're dealing with
for example in education
schools are responsible to to keep
enrollment information in perpetuity
so and if you if you have federal grants
you there's a requirement that you keep
certain pieces of information
for a certain length of time and then of
course anything that with licensing
there could be lawsuits so you want it I
would think you know statute of
limitations would apply so it it's not
like all of your information it can be
some of your information in the
retention policy could be different for
different pieces of it I don't think it
this whole issue doesn't lie just with
the architis
if I if I may Madam chair please the
policy that was approved by archives is
on our website and does describe the
different types of documents and have
different types of retention schedules
based on the documents
and that information is in fact
available to the public yes it's on our
website
okay
there's a motion in the second one okay
there are no no more discussion than the
motion is to approve the rule
those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much
okay court reporters um we've already
talked about the cost recovery versus
license fee so I won't talk about that
however the fees do not match uh the
fees and this proposal say 155 for
initial reinstatement and renewal that's
a piece but the rules that you've just
approved previously for
2023-52 say 300 for initial and
reinstatement fees 204 renewal so
they're um so that's a problem that the
fees do not match in this proposal
second there is just to point out to you
there is a 100 difference between the
initial and reinstatement fee of three
hundred dollars
to the two hundred dollars for Renewal
so in this instance perhaps the um as
you stated chairwoman McGuire the the
cost recovery may be a hundred dollars
difference and so this proposal and the
rules that you just approved in 52 could
probably be amended to reflect that
um there's another issue and we've
already talked about at the retention
schedule so I won't spend any time on
that the next issue to bring to your
attention is there are some statutory
conflicts that will need to be addressed
in the next session and that's around
the term of licenses and we're seeing it
a lot with a lot of the initial
proposals that are coming in so the oplc
statute conflicts with the board
statutes the board statutes generally
say that the license that's expired
during the licensees birth month but the
oplc statute states that it expires
during the month of issuance so that's
probably going to be confusing for some
licensees they do have a notification on
their website about it but the committee
may want to know what Outreach has been
done beyond that notification so that
licensees aren't taken by surprise and
then lastly the link in the appendix is
not accurate so but that can be fixed at
since Senator ward has left would you
like to replace a point somebody in the
replacement representative hacken
Phillips can sit in for Senator Ward
okay
uh yes thank you I think there are two
issues here um the first regarding the
statutory conflicts we are very aware of
the statutory conflicts this is part of
um what will hopefully be another
cleanup effort in the next legislative
session
um regarding the terms uh with 655s
passing
um I I believe it makes clear that all
licenses are slated to expire two years
after the date of issuance
um the way we've implemented this uh is
Forward Thinking obviously not changing
existing dates but changing them as they
are issued so upon renewal if they have
always renewed on their birthday
assuming they were new on time they will
continue to always Renew on their
birthday because the last date of
issuance is their birthday
um in terms of communications to the
public we did send out an email blast we
also have posted this information I
believe on every board web page and we
really haven't gotten a lot of inquiries
um or individuals confused about that
with respect to the first issue with the
fees
honestly that I take uh responsibility
for this one uh the uh what we had
intended to do with the PLC 1002s is
really not changed or deviate from
existing fees at all
um because we what we were trying to do
is just get all the fees into one
document so we can avoid this whole
every board adopts a fee the prior fees
for for the court reporters when we
started working on this were 300 and 200
the 300 I believe was set in statute and
so that's why that was included
um but if you may recall two years ago I
had presented some fees for the board's
consideration that didn't go anywhere it
ended up becoming part of a discussion
with the SB 330 committee but we had
recommended modifying the fee for court
reporters to 155.
um so what I would suggest is that this
this rule really should just point to
the PLC 1002s and to the extent that
anything needs to be modified in the
future that we will make those
modifications in the 1002s so just to be
clear
um the fee is 155 and will you be
amending the um the rule set that was
just approved in 2020 352.
to indicate a 155p
so so I believe this this proposal
should be amended to reflect that it
that we are utilizing the fees set forth
in the PLC 1002s the PLC 1002s I believe
were just approved and included fee for
300 200. exactly which has always been
the fee for court reporters
um we will obviously
need to reament the PLC 1002s after
undertaking additional analysis
um
but I suspect that those fees will
representative you had a question okay
anyone or Senator line so are you
suggesting that in in this one in 12 4 2
where it says applying for initial
license section three that says 155 we
should strike number three or have it
just reference 102 the other statute we
just and that would be the amendment you
would agree to exactly reference the
1002s pay the fee as described in 1002
all right we'll have some people
bouncing around looking for the rules so
I hope they're they're obvious move to
approve as amended for conditional
approval as I mentioned by Senator
Chandler I believe yeah Senator
Ennis all right any further comments
okay those in favor
aye opposed
and if there is in fact a statutory fee
that we want to take add that to the
list of things we need to take a look at
okay
Board of Podiatry
so this one
um
has the exact same comment about the
licensing
um and that's the only issue that that's
so given that we've already had
discussion ad nauseum on that I've moved
by reference Honorable in any comments
okay seeing none those in favor
Chandler
Madam chairman yes
um just for the record
um
I'm I believe that Senator Lang's motion
included conditionally approving the
rule to make the same insertion as in
the motion was to deal with the adoption
to change at number three to say the
fees were set by 1002 rather than have
the fee in the rule exactly thank you
okay
okay the only issue on this one is
actually that there were a couple
definitions that expired in 2006
um
good morning Nicole valenzola
administrative rules coordinator for the
Department of Health and Human Services
um Madam chair actually if I can bring
some clarification to this previously
the area agency had sectioned out their
definitions in a specific formatting
where each section
.01.02 was a different word
they are now reformatting and clumping
definitions based upon you know alphabet
so the section was was a previous word
that is no longer utilized and hasn't
been used and so the section was
reserved but per aarl language we have
to write expired but there isn't
actually expired language
um and the words that are now in that
section are new terms to be defined
so the previous word that was .02 is
cash account and that term isn't used
any longer and the new term now is I
so you're saying that the
definitions that expired in 2006 are no
longer used as such correct it was one
word in that section that hasn't been
used
expired
it's been reserved I don't know for how
long that section so
indefinitely as far as I
so we you know we might have shot
ourselves there in the foot by even
saying it was expired but that's my
fault
you know that's the only issue we'll do
a group exactly okay
and then I'm Madam chair I don't know I
had one that was pulled off consent
while I'm up here or I'm happy to go
back and sit and wait if you wanted
oh I'm sorry one at a time
uh yeah I think we'll we'll deal with
the ones off consent last that's the
usual procedure all right do we have a
motion I already moved to approve oh
sentence sentence it has been moved and
approved moved and seconded to approve
the rule any further discussion comments
seeing none those in favor
opposed
okay thank you sorry for that
interruption
uh so the next is uh
2023-6 it's an expedited revision to
form
um there are two comments on this
particular proposal one's an unclear and
one is simply a note to the committee uh
both have to do with the fact that this
rule uh excuse me this form
was uh just amended back in 2022 through
the same process the expedited version
of form process
and in the notice the second
change it says that it's changing the
requirement from U.S citizen to Legal
resonated by the agency I could not see
that those uh Federal uh regulations had
been amended recently so I was not sure
why uh this change was happening now as
opposed to 2022
um and the other issue was
um as I said it's a note to jail car
because it's not a grounds for objection
however if the committee feels that this
needs to be addressed they can certainly
do a petition for rulemaking but the
form
um after it was mended in 2022 the rule
text was not updated to reflect the new
name of the form and the new edition
date as you can see from this rule uh
this proposal there are two rule
sections where this form is referenced
and both of them have the old name of
yes please good morning Allison radmay
administrator for the administrative
rules unit in the Department of Health
and Human Services
bureau chief for family centered
services
okay I'm going to uh address the note to
gel car with respect to the
inconsistency of the form title and
Edition date in the rule text on the Jen
import website
um
I was no part
um involved in the 2022 revisions
however after looking through the
records in our office
um it has come to our conclusion that we
have not received the proofing copy
um that allows us to make those changes
on the actual rule text uh on the
genport website and we did make sure we
did not miss that so that's why that is
outstanding
um
isn't this something that the process
for expedited forms is supposed to
include that you update the reference
in the rule itself yes if there's no
substantive change then that can be done
editorially if there's a substantive
change created by the revision to the
form then they also have to go through
rule making for the text of the rule
I see so the in both cases there is in
fact a substantive change
in this instance yes then they would
need regular rulemaking okay thank you
regarding the question about the federal
requirement it's not a it wasn't a
change in the federal requirement it's a
clarification it refers to 42 USC
which is part of the Medicaid
requirements the Social Security Act
references that individuals served must
also meet the requirements for that and
because the requirements include U.S
citizen or a legal resident alien alien
lawfully admitted for permanent
residents given the space we had
available on the form we felt that using
a legal resident of the United States
would cover both of those which is why
we chose that um
phrase
questions
comments
representative
thank you madam chair I'm trying to
understand you said that it needs to
comply with the Social Security
Administration
um is it it sounds like the Social
Security Administration is a broader
application than what this rule is what
went that then then the other
requirements is that correct that you're
broadening it
to fit with the Social Security
Administration so the title V funds that
are used to support the services
provided under this rule are issued
unallocated under the social Social
Security Act when we reviewed the ACT to
make sure that we were meeting all the
requirements in our application it
referenced
um also being in compliance with these
Medicaid rules when we cross-referenced
those that's when we
found that language
so it's not that we're broadening it I
representative yeah you know I I
understand what you're saying and my
only concern is um
if you I I certainly agree that a legal
resident includes a citizen but I'm
wondering if that term
you know if in other words if I just saw
the term legal somebody that that
you know that
um that maybe has some knowledge and if
I just saw the term legal resident I
might wonder if that includes a citizen
even though I even though I agree it
does I mean it just seems like
wouldn't it wouldn't it be in terms of
sort of public understanding wouldn't it
be better to use both terms a U.S
that's fine
that's just a suggestion
okay
uh Madam chair uh because this is an
expedited revision to form I don't think
you can do a conditional approval
that's correct you either have to deny
and I I I would draw my you know do you
have a motion to approve yes I've moved
to approve
okay representative Lynn moves to
approve I'll second with the
edition of a request for rulemaking to
update the references in the rules that
refer to this form
can I actually clarify that with you
guys during the certification process
once we put a rule a former Vision
forward can't we amend the title in the
Edition date as part of the
certification process
if there's no other changes in the
but it would probably be editorial but I
think we would have to look because I
feel like that's how we've always done
it so I'm I'm just kind of confused yeah
well the
if there is a substantial a policy
change then we would want you to update
the rules that refer to this form
and you're saying there is not a policy
change no
so there's no change in the form that
would require uh complementary ruleming
no not other than the rule title and the
addition name and if I make I mean the
form title I believe this form is
incorporated by reference is that
correct so there's no there's nothing in
the rule text that needs to be amended
except for the title and the Edition
okay so that could be an editorial
change
yes okay then I withdraw withdraw the
the request and just second the motion
thank you
any further discussion comments
questions
okay those in favor
aye aye opposed
all right the next one is the objection
response for 2022 241 case management
agencies
um
so I have reviewed the
um agency's
objection response and
um I
complied with the federal statute
um
and they did take into consideration
stakeholder
um
testimony
however there are actually a few typos
but
I would like to go over
um
there there some of them are definitely
typos that should be
um
dealt with
so
on page
nine
um the uh letter k
it refers you from K to K and it should
be J which is the
the statute or the the rule above it
um
on page
[Music]
um
they're missing an s in
six
a
um
on page 15
I'm sorry page
18 15 a
um
they should triple the original fine
for making the fine less
in the in the section above
and so I I don't know if they're
actually changing there's no way for
um
in any way
so that's just a little confusing there
um
and then
um page 21 they have an extra and
oh yeah and then page 25 again they they
have a paragraph H that they're referred
um
on page 26
they're referring to K and they mean J
um and then they have a wrong citation
the G number three
um K3 they're referring to G3 and it's
actually F3
so some of those need to be
need to be fixed just because so these
are these are generally editorial
yes they could they could do those
editorially
um but
that's those were the only issues I
found so like they they appear to be um
complying with the federal statute
um and like I said they they did take
into consideration the concerns from
um stakeholders okay we have a request
for public testimony so uh
thank you madam cheetah for the record
my name is Robert Clegg and I'm
representing
um Granite State case management
we're here to talk about the letter
excuse me representative Schmidt so we
don't have
um Sano today so this is the record so
you got to be really talking into the
microphone so they the record writer
will have even a chance at getting this
down so thank you thank you
um and again for the record my name is
Robert Clegg I'm here representing
Greenwich case management and we're here
in response to the letter that came from
Department of Health and Human Services
and I want to clarify a few things one
we had always thought from the beginning
that we were talking about case
management agencies because that's what
was on the on the rule however we see
here that they consider case management
agencies to include hospitals nursing
homes Home Health agencies assisted
living facilities residential
Rehabilitation residential psychiatric
treatment substance abuse disorder
residential facilities non-emergency
walk-in Care Centers ambulatory surgical
centers and Stage renal dialysis centers
Community residents Adult Day Care
Centers and hospice care
we didn't agree until we saw it here we
agree now because we understand that
there's parity in the rates and the
rates paid to the hospitals for those
Services
exceed what we get so we'll be doing a
right to know to make sure that
everybody's treated equally
however
the problem that we have is that
the the
rule that they're trying to do
is is not proper they're saying that
there is no CMS
intervention and rules than there is CMS
has a law has a rule that says if you
have case management licensing everybody
has to be licensed you can't go
willy-nilly and decide oh yes for this
one and know for that one it's either
we also want to want you to understand
what a case management does
case management doesn't just say to a
patient here's what you're going to do
in fact one of the reasons that we've
always had a problem with area agencies
is when you're the one providing the
service
and then you're the one that determines
whether or not you provided that service
correctly
it seems to be a problem
case management agencies such as Granite
State case management
has always been the one that says to the
state the client doesn't need that
service
and a lot of times they say you're being
billed for service that the client's not
receiving
so it's actually the eyes and the ears
of the state and helps to keep us from
paying for things that are never done
it also stops a a patient or a client
from not getting the services that the
absolute absolutely positively need
now we also see that
they say that New Hampshire is under a
new plan of of Correction
yeah it's the same plan and correction
that they've been trying to do
in the legislature bill after Bill in
the last two years has said no to
and we find it insulting that day before
you're out of session
they put in an emergency rule
and for the record I know that an
emergency rule becomes the law whether
you like it or I like it so basically
it's another usurpation of the
legislative prerogative of how to run
things
we have shown up every single time the
legislature has asked us to comment
we show up at this committee to make
sure that everybody understands how we
feel
and we fee again insulted only one
person showed up
well you know we we have work to do too
we showed up at gel car it doesn't take
all of us it just takes some of us to
let you understand where we are
and where we are right now is
Joe Carr needs to somehow find a way to
stop the Department of Health and Human
Services from creating constant law even
after the legislature says no to what
they're doing
we're going to assist by filing
something next year that says if you
can't get gel Carr to say yes it's a no
there has to be some kind of legislative
oversight and they should not be allowed
to wait to the last minute and say yeah
thanks a lot I was here in 94.
and I remember what they used to say
they used to say fine well wait till you
go home in the summer and we'll do it in
Rule and for years we stop them from
doing that and what I see now is I see
an arrogance
that basically says to the gel car
committee and the entire legislature we
don't really care what you think you may
be elected but we're the bureaucrats and
we're going to do it anyways
so I'm asking you to to not approve this
rule I understand it's going to go
through whether we like it or not
because you can't even stop that
but we need to say no and and we'll be
back again in January
and and we'll fight again
but we're asking for your help and we're
asking for you to act as the elected
representatives thank you
I'm not familiar with any legislative
attempt to deal to deal with it this
year could you clarify what part of this
you think is against legislative intent
well there's been numerous bills Senate
Bill 333 talked about licensing we've
had the argument in in the Committees
and I don't remember which Committee in
the senate in the house they were but
but the legislature decided that we were
correct the legislature has consistently
agreed that CMS does have the ability to
say if you license one you have to
license all
um so so
um
I'll stand corrected if it wasn't Senate
Bill 333 but it was a bill this year
um that we put in that you have to be
licensed so we've covered ourselves
constantly so
who needs to be licensed
anybody in case management needs to be
licensed everybody it's either that or
nobody is licensed but the law requires
that anybody providing case management
needs to be licensed and this rule
apparently says that if you're licensed
as a hospital you can do case management
on the side
is that the issue that you're dealing
with according to what DHHS is saying
all of these people are doing case
I want to pitch in go ahead
no I'm I would agree I mean you
introduce yourself I apologize I'm Emily
Johnson I'm with granite case management
um thanks for for hearing me this
morning
um yeah I
was I don't have much clarification
honestly
um
but
yes
um the emergency rule which is this is
not the emergency rule
this is the general rule on case
management agencies and I believe the
emergency rule does require everyone
to be uh
license not license but right it's not
just going to be the area or agencies
it's anyone providing services
there is uh Carolyn virtue Granite case
management there is a statute
um
I believe that's RSA 1 51
e colon B1 but I may have that citation
off that requires licensure of case
management agencies
beginning on July 1st through yesterday
the department has enrolled over 30
individuals or entities to deliver case
management two of them are licensed CMS
requires that if state law or rule
requires licensure that in order to
enroll a provider the department must
verify that that licensure exists
the department did not do that
they are not
licensing providers as required
and they're trying to have an exemption
in this rule
but there's no statutory basis for it
thank you director Morrow
um I just want to let everyone know the
committee and the public that this is an
objection response so the committee has
the choice of approving the rule
entering a final objection and or joint
resolution
and that's basically it unless the
agency requests a revised objection and
any further basis for objection has to
be based on what the committee's
objection was to the final proposal
which was there was in part well there
was staff annotations and the War uh
legislative intent to the extent that
the rules were unclear
so does this rule conflict with the
statute
um I do not believe that it does but I I
think that the
agency may be able to explain it a
little bit better
and to qualify what I just said yes if
the agency in changing the language in
the ejection response from the final
proposal create a new basis for
objection and certainly the committee
can take that into consideration
okay
I think so unless there's any questions
well
well we will hear from the agency next
are there any questions for Mr Clegg no
okay thank you ask one question yes Bob
so having read what the agencies reviled
it after our original objection
does the same situation still exist
where we're dealing with agencies
providing care also saying that they're
providing care properly and there's no
is that problem still exists that's been
something that they're trying to do it
still exists yes thank you I I want to
clarify what I said though you have to
understand that the Department of Health
and Department of Health and Human
Services I'm sorry Peter
Department of Health and Human Services
continuously tries to say to CMS that
there are no licensed case managers with
conflict-free abilities in the state of
New Hampshire now there were two with
over 40 years experience
so while they keep telling the federal
I would like it may ask representative
thank you I would like clarification on
that Senate bill number because Senate
Bill 333 does concern case management
but it was passed by the house in the
Senate so I don't I'd like I don't
really understand your
concern about
the intent we amended out the parts that
they have in here we amended out the
ability for them to allow unlicensed
people
and there was another bill as well it's
representative lamb um thank you madam
chair my question is regarding the
section that is deleted in this response
it was deleted section F which Exempted
all entities who provide Service
Coordination to individuals receiving
developmental disability services or
acquired brain disorders by making that
deletion is this moving further away
from parity among providers for
Licensing in regard to the CMS
requirements I would I would personally
thank you okay
other questions thank you very much uh
for the record my name is Dorian
Shockley I'm the manager at the Bureau
of Licensing and certification at the
RSA 151 colon do you want me to just
respond or did you have specific
questions or please respond first I'm
sure we'll have other questions there
was a lot of information there so I'll
do my very best RSA 151 colon 2 Dash B
describes home health care provider and
individual home care service provider
means
directions
senator
I'll be happy to go
not yet please okay
means any organization business entity
or subdivision thereof including a case
management agency whether public or
private whether operated for profit or
not which is engaged in arranging or
providing directly or through contact
contract Arrangement one or more of the
following nursing Services home health
aid services or other therapeutic and
related Services which may include but
shall not be limited to physical and
occupational therapy Speech Pathology
nutritional services medical social
services personal care services and
Homemaker Services which may be of a
preventive Therapeutic rehabilitative
Health guidance or supportive nature to
persons in their places of residence
Hep 819 defines Home Health
I'm sorry Case Management agency means
an organization in consultation with the
client in the client's place of Resident
arranges for and coordinates the
delivery of care and services to meet
the physical emotional medical nursing
Financial legal and social services
needs of the client
the first objection was to remove f
from the scope of work which is what we
did
and that's what we're responding to in
the testimony prior to me it was
asserted that the Department of Health
and Human Services considers
hospitals nursing homes Home Health
agencies assisted living facilities the
reason that we exempt these facilities
they are already licensed and regulated
in the state of New Hampshire so if we
are asking now for every single licensed
agency to be licensed for every service
they provide you now will have hospitals
nursing homes assisted living facilities
having more than one license and having
a lot of visits from us and also in our
opinion
and has been a long-standing policy or
in the state of New Hampshire is not to
over regulate individuals rather we
review all of the services and programs
for each licensed facility
to the point so if I understand you
correctly your interpretation of the
license all or none is that these
individuals are licensed as
say a home
hospital and case management is one of
their their license functions and they
have a lab and they don't need a lab
license so hospitals would need many
licenses for all the services they
probably provide as with nursing homes
add with as would assisted living
facilities
it's very helpful say 151 colon 2-b is
not referenced in this rule however it
says all licensed Healthcare entities
would it help to clarify that the RSA
that that that facilities with case
management agencies license under 151
colon 2B are Exempted would that would
okay so all licensed Health Care
entities
licensed pursuant to RSA 151 colon 2-b
is that what you're suggesting
um I'm afraid that I might kick
something out as well but if you
included one you have all licenses a is
all facilities listed in RSA 151 colon 2
comma two a through I but if you added
one that includes all facilities listed
um all facilities providing case
management licensed under 151 colon 2
Dash B that would make sure that all of
those groups do not need to pursue
another license but we're clarifying
that anybody who falls within that is
exempt from this case management license
so iding other services that require
licensure so we'd have to go back and
take a look at that too but I think we
could probably make a clarification on
that I
okay I appreciate that I think that'd
help a lot thank you Senator Lang
so I guess my my stumbling block here is
the fact that while I recognize they
have a specific license that's more of a
global license that deals with it my
question is there anywhere else in rules
that requires to make sure that they
also follow these guidelines for
um or the or the guidelines for
um
case management agencies is there
something that says that while you have
a license that's up here you also have
to make sure you're following these
rules because basically I I don't want
the fox guard in the hen house right
without some sort of Regulation that
deals with that and to a certain extent
that's my concern right is that I want
to make sure that yeah you may be able
to allow to provide Case Management
Services because of your Global license
but understand there's some firewall
rules you have to deal with to make sure
that the auditing and all that work is
done properly and is that in place yes
thank you for your question and your
comments and yes all of our rules like a
hospital is a good example but also I
mean they're also CMS certified and or
accredited from different accrediting
agencies so they have a great deal of
oversight but they um the hospital rules
also
um talk to all of the different types of
services Radiology Cardiology I mean all
of the services they provide and what
quality measures are in place to ensure
that patients are safe and healthy yes
does that answer your question
I'm not sure my concern is all I
understand there may be Federal
Regulation we're talking about state
regulations Case Management Services and
so my question again is
do they have to
abide by the same regulatory same state
requirements because they hold that that
larger license that and that a smaller
agency that may only do Case Management
Services also has to abide by to make
sure that there's that firewall of of
services that there's not cross bleeding
over from oversight so RSA 151 I'm not
sure which particular section
um
is titled deemed licensed so hospitals
again are not a really good example but
hospitals are deemed licensed because
they are certified by CMS so I have a
CMS team and then I have a State
Licensing team and then there's the
external to the state agency a a
crediting agency of the Hospital's
Choice
they are deemed licensed which means it
is expected that they are compliant with
everything that's in state law and state
rule but they're overseen by the feds
and it's just presumed always that the
Federal Regulations are more stringent
than the state regulations if there's a
contradiction there then our licensing
team gets involved or the accrediting
agency we also have a regional office in
Boston that works with us on that too
but again hospitals may not be a really
good example because they're very
they're different so but nursing homes
we would make sure that both our
licensing team and our CMS team are
making sure that they are compliant with
rules and law federal
state
this sounds like a horrendous mess
[Music]
I don't know what that means well
it means that we have Federal
requirements and federal regulations and
state rules and regulations and they
interact with each other
so I think it's important to note that
the comments that were made prior to my
coming up here there is a discussion
about payment mechanisms and an
emergency rule that's separate from
licensing New Hampshire statute requires
licensure for facilities that provide
certain services so our Bureau oversees
that licensing and to the point that the
agencies that were identified on July 1
not being licensed they are in fact in
the process of becoming licensed
um so
license you can't list them as licensed
entities
so they're not listed as licensed
entities they're in the process the
activity whatever system changed
effective July 1. if we were to say as a
state all of these individuals that are
receiving services from this handful or
less case management agencies that
effective 7-1 required a license prior
to 7-1 they didn't require A license
they require a license we're actively
working with them to get them licensed
if we were to stop their services then
all of those individuals would no longer
have services
so we're working in good faith to have
and I want to also point out that the
Department of Health and Human Services
is a very large agency so to think that
licensing is responsible for everything
that's hap I mean I I guess sometimes I
get lost in in the com and I'm sorry
this isn't time for me to I'll stop but
[Music]
thank you Peter
director Morrow if uh if any further
change were to be made as suggested by
representative Leon because this is an
objection response the agency would have
to request a revised objection
which would end up back before Joe
Kerrigan
does the agency wish to request that
they're thinking representative
I'm just wondering whether or not we're
just making this too complicated
I don't think that this is as big of a
mess as it is because whenever you bring
in intentions and
you you uh have
two organizations that obviously don't
agree then that's going to create a mess
in itself so I just think we need to
look at it as a
um
strictly on a merit basis
if that if that's helpful okay well then
it would does the agency agree to put a
revised objection response
that would incorporate the
clarifications that representative Leon
asked for
yes we agreed to that okay then
yes
um thank you madam chair um I I just
want to make sure that with this in
process you'll still be able to get the
area the get those people licensed that
need to be licensed in order to provide
care to this community
because the process by the time we're
back here and we approve that with that
condition they'll already be in that
process of Licensing and it doesn't move
faster than that does it yeah and and to
correct it's not area agencies that are
in the process of being licensed because
they're exempt it's those agencies that
were part of F that we had initially put
in and the first objection that we're
here to discuss today we removed that
um so those are the agencies that we are
actively working on becoming licensed
so the delay would not interfere with
that process that's correct okay
thank you thank you in that case
um we have the agency has requested a
revised objection response do we need to
vote to to accept it
well there's um there's another option
um you you could approve this and then
come back through with rulemaking for
that one section
if the agency is is willing which well
which is the least trouble for everybody
involved
yeah I would yeah it would be to approve
this and start again on regular
rulemaking so we can at least get these
changes in place
I'll move to do that to to approve this
with the
um intention of uh correcting the taking
into account the measures representative
Leon suggested I'll second okay
representative Liam and I I do want to
clarify that this is a clarification so
that there's not misinterpretation that
this rule is already intended to cover
anybody licensed under the one a 151
colon 2B and the simple the rule change
is there a second
yes thank you sir
okay the motion is to approve the rule
those in favor
aye opposed
okay Senator Lang is opposed
um
okay
so the next item on the list the
objection response for 20 23.89
um we have not received that response
yet but they have not met their deadline
their deadline is until July 31st so
they still have a little more time okay
we will not do anything on that then
um so with regard to 2023 106 this was a
late filed final proposal that did get a
waiver for the um
final proposal deadline I had three
comments on it that have already been
discussed the fee issue the retention
policy issue and then the uh renewal
date issue have all already been
addressed so I had no further comments
yes we're we're in the discussion period
And I have a question
uh I had some public comment that the
this board had recently increased its
continuing education requirements and do
you are you familiar with that and do
you know what the statutory Authority is
I believe
I believe that it could be referring to
a Respiratory Care not Medical Imaging
um
they do have statutory authority over
continuing education or the office does
because it's an Advisory Board we did
recently have a meeting a public meeting
on June 8th to discuss this issue
um interestingly I think stakeholders
are mixed about how many hours should be
required but I think the consensus was
that the increase in continuing
education should not apply to this
upcoming renewal cycle
um
so we do plan to Institute rulemaking to
on board
are there any other questions comments
okay
the motion is to approve the rule
those in favor
aye opposed
Senator Chandler vote snap okay
Madam chair the next item under our
um
hem 504
staff has looked at this to see whether
there does exist a basis for an
emergency Rule and it appears based on
the filing from the Department that it
meets both the requirements for imminent
apparel to imminent Peril to Public
Health or safety as well as
a potential significant risk of
financial impact to the state but that
can certainly be further explained by
the agency
okay thank you
good morning for the record my name is
Melissa Nemeth an attorney with the
Bureau of Developmental Services
um and hem 504 is a new rule for a
provider and provider agency operations
as we have discussed here in the context
of some other rules lately the
department has been under a corrective
action plan with CMS that we needed to
comply with by July 1st that included a
few different elements some of the key
elements where the department needed to
ensure that providers of Developmental
Services were able to Bill Medicaid
directly because historically there had
only been the 10 area agencies had been
the only enrolled Medicaid providers and
they had contracted out with service
providers so that was one element that
needed to be corrected as well as
ensuring that services to individuals
are free from conflict and so that was
as a I said the department needed to be
in compliance with these requirements by
July 1st this has been
coming into compliance with the
corrective action plan has been multiple
years in the making
um but this
we kind of couldn't get to this final
stage we had to First ensure that we
stay with the area agencies and what
roles we're going to transfer to
Providers directly and so that work was
still being done up until a few months
ago
the contract with area agencies needed
to be revised to distinguish their
functions and so that is some of the
reason that this was coming as an
emergency Rule and there was not a Time
previously to go through the regular
rulemaking process
we we did send the department sent this
out to a draft of this emergency rule
out to uh it wasn't labeled as an
emergency rule a draft of the rule was
sent out to relevant stakeholders at the
beginning of May and asked them gave
them a month and asked them to get back
to us with any comments it was made
clear to them at the time that due to
the timing you know it was likely that
critical elements might need to be
implemented via an emergency rule the
department received a significant amount
of feedback and in fact was able to
incorporate a lot of that into the
emergency rule that you see before you
today and we are working as we speak on
the the regular rule to get this to make
sure there are no gaps
to address the points that attorney
Morrell had brought up the imminent
Peril piece as I said previously area
agencies contracted with providers so
via that contract they had what we refer
to as like a screening process or a
vetting process for these providers they
oversaw their operations and were able
to do the billing
those are important pieces that needed
to be overseen by someone they couldn't
there could not be a gap in services so
the imminent Peril is at if there were
no mechanism for any oversight or
enrollment of these providers we
wouldn't have standardization and that
could put people at risk if there were
you know
no standards these people to provide the
services as far as the financial concern
if we were not to be in compliance with
the corrective action plan by the first
of July the state was at significant
risk of losing its 50 Medicaid match for
these Services
which would then mean one of two things
the funds would need to come strictly
from General funds that had not been
allocated which could be a significant
cost or if those funds were not
available it would mean that these folks
then would necessarily go without the
services again speaking to the imminent
Peril that this could have put
individuals in for so for those reasons
on the department felt that it was
necessary to go forward with the
when were you put under a corrective
action plan how long ago was that
I believe it was in 2017.
so seven years ago I believe that's
accurate yes
and we have to have an emergency rule
for something you knew about seven years
ago and we kind of anticipated that
question um and as I said it was this
has been worked on all of the steps to
come into compliance with the corrective
action plan have been in process since
that time
um but this this piece about what were
the requirements for these providers of
services going to be decoupling that
from area agencies which where it had
been a part of what they had done and
contracted for we had to First make sure
we understood what the functions of the
area agency were going to remain before
we could determine what they were how
they were going to
transfer to provider agencies and that
work has the the stakeholder uh work
with respect to that has been extremely
robust there are a multitude of
subcommittees and advisory councils that
had been working on that and
those functions that are going to remain
with area agencies I you may or may not
have seen we have filed an initial
proposal of hem 505 so some elements are
there and then the elements
that are not yet adopted in the rule
we're in the contract with between the
department area agencies which was just
finalized and approved by governor and
council at the end of June so cut all
these things were kind of converging on
the same time frame
hello follow up so I guess my question
is in here it talks about July 1 which
we've already passed and what does that
mean for services that have been
provided between July 1 and now that
we're out of compliance because we
haven't adopted no this is an emergency
rule it went into effect right oh it's
already been in effect yes on June 28th
yes
and another another complication is that
there was the contracts between the area
agencies and the provider agencies that
were through the end of June to provide
okay
anyone else represent Bland thank you
madam chair thank you for getting these
rules out I think that this is a large
reason why as we have the different
bills coming through on this we were
really encouraging the department to
seek another waiver so that we could go
through this rulemaking process in a
more measured and um and noticed way
um I just want to say that that is why
we had sought why we had encourage the
department to seek another waiver so
that we weren't coming in at the last
minute I appreciate the work that you've
done but but I'd like to see more more
I do have one comment because I've I've
heard from the
uh case management agencies that they
believe they are stakeholders in this
process and they were not consulted
during this this rulemaking
and I wonder if you have any comments on
that my understanding is that those
entities that are providing services
that we're providing services to this
community and now we're part of what who
would be regulated under here were
included I do not have the list in front
of me specifically but my understanding
is that it went out to a very very broad
stakeholder community
and I don't know specifically which
agencies were included
it was primarily those who are currently
in the business well and so to speak and
this would this rule is for providers
both if they're providing direct service
and Service Coordination so it went out
to Providers of both of those types of
services but if they if an agency was
not already providing those services to
this community they may not have been
included in the in that stakeholder
Outreach because it wasn't known to the
department they were the regulated
Community thank you
anyone else questions comments all right
Direction More wrong
um in addition to the Department of
Safety under other business we still
have I believe two final proposals
remaining that we're taking off consent
okay
Department of Safety
um
okay so um last time the committee had
approved the driver's licensing rules
and requested that the department of
safety report back on its internal
policy to ensure that forms are not
updated outside the rulemaking process
they had adopted this policy last year
and are slowly going through each rule
set to look at those forms but um you
should have as part of your packages
good morning Steve Lavoy assistant
commissioner at the department of safety
and with me is John rasco the director
so um the letter that was presented to
you was really addressing three
questions that came up during uh the
adoption of the 1000 rules the first
being how we're addressing the forms uh
issues that we've identified
um first and foremost I want the
committee to know the commissioner and I
both want the committee to know that we
recognize the importance of having forms
go through rulemaking it's critical
um it's what we're doing at this point
is taking an inventory of all of our
approved forms and reconciling those
against those that are currently in use
to identify what those gaps are and what
that population is once we've identified
that population that needs to be
adjusted will be determining if there's
substantive changes or if there are
editorial changes and incorporate those
into our current rule making schedule as
needed based on that risk assessment so
we're working through the process we do
ask for your patients because we have a
lot of rule sets to go through a lot of
forms to go through I don't think every
form in the department of safety D has
an issue we don't know how many
um but the ones that are we will address
as quickly as possible
another question that came up had to do
with um
actually I think it was representative
Leon related to um
suspended driver's licenses and whether
those needed to be suspend um
surrendered to the department
um that's a situation where uh a few
years back the department worked with
the legislature to
um become part of state to state and
make some adjustments to statute related
to how suspended licenses are handled
we thought collaboratively that we had
addressed all the changes that were
necessary in statute but it turns out
there were sections that were missed
during that process and that's the
situation that we're dealing with here
so we have a group of individuals when
their license is suspended that do not
need to surrender however there is a
group that fall under some categories
some exemptions to that including the
administrative license suspensions the
ALS process that do need to suspend or
Surrender
unfortunately the DMV staff were telling
everyone they didn't they no longer
needed to surrender that was a that was
a missed change in that legislative
process will be working internally to
determine what needs to be changed
through legislative changes and work
finding a sponsor in the next session to
see about whether or not the legislature
wants to
align both of those processes together
and the key there is the the big
difference in the driver license is not
only a credential that authorizes you
the privilege to drive but also is used
as an ID now and so that's why not
surrendering it seems to be something
that we would want to consider
and then the third question was
representative Lynn it was related to a
question on non-resident pistol permits
and there was a Supreme Court decision
that indicated that the rules and the
forms that we were using were no longer
valid when that decision came forward we
did go through the normal form approval
process adjusted the forms and those
have been in place since that time but
as was pointed out the rules themselves
were not cleaned up to eliminate the
language that was no longer necessary
that change has since been filed with
the next rule set that was submitted I
want to say maybe a week or so ago and
so those were the three questions that
we were reporting back on and we're
happy to take any questions that the
thank you madam chair and thank you for
those clarifications I'd be happy to
talk with you about the legislative
changes thank you thank you okay
and I do have that
um those pistol rules okay we have the
um
we have the initial proposal
representative Lim sure
um it's uh if I understand correctly it
from your letter it sounds like
the form was changed back in 2017 but
the language and the rule
has not actually yet been changed I mean
it's in the works but it hasn't actually
come
come to us is that correct yes correct
that um so that's
seven years
since that decision was made and
I have to say honestly that's very
concerning this is something that sort
of concerns a constitutional right
uh implicates a constitutional right uh
under the Second Amendment and you know
the court issues a decision
and seven years later the language in
the uh in the rule that the court has
struck down is you know is has not yet
been changed
that that's a concern that's really a
concern that this that that goes on for
either that or the department has been
ignoring their rules for seven years
well yeah I understood and I share that
concern and just to alleviate it um the
form is really what's uh the the the
mechanism to provide these resident
these non-resident permits so the result
of the decision has been effectively
implemented correctly the only thing
that hasn't been is the the cleanup of
those rules behind it so there hasn't
been any any issue with the
implementation of the program after that
decision was made but I agree though
I mean I hope that's true but I guess
you know the thing that I'm that would
be of concern to me is if I'm if I'm
if I'm someone in New Jersey as you know
I use New Jersey because that was where
that person came from in the in the bot
case but if I'm someone in New Jersey
um who wants to get a New Hampshire
non-resident pistol permit
argue and and if I'm someone that maybe
is you know uh it wants to be a sort of
a thorough person it might be that the
first thing I would do is look up the
regular the law and the regulations in
New Hampshire and when I read the
regulations I would see that
nothing has you know that that it still
contains that language which is was
unauthorized so
that that's I mean I'm glad I'm glad
things are you know we're we've got the
changes in the process I just it's
unfortunate that it took so long that's
all I'd say thanks understood and that's
a fair point
director tomorrow
um
staff shares representative Lynn's
concern about a time delay between
change and a form that substantively
affects an existing rule that would not
occur where a form is being Incorporated
by reference and then the form needed to
change because it is being Incorporated
by reference where it would occur is if
the form uh is in addition to the text
of the rule and a change in the form
required would require a complimentary
change to the text of the rule we've
discussed that we're not sure yet how
it's best to be well it would need to be
addressed in legislation but whether a
time period needs to be set for an
agency to go ahead and adopt a rule
to com to comport with the
form or what's the best mechanism yet
well I wish you luck you've got a lot of
forms that people carry around and
controlling the additions is not a not a
thank you
nothing this was it we already approved
the rule this is we had a question and
they answered it
all right so the the
um
once I'm consent or the last two the
last two things off consent
um
and the first one is 2023
23 about
um esol teachers yes and we had a
question that they were going to get
okay
good morning um for the record Julie
Shea administrative rules coordinator
for the Department of Education
I did reach out to the director and
um the answer that I was given is that
the federal definition and law will
always override the state rule that
being said
um I don't think a definition within
teacher certification would affect any
sort of funding for English language
Learners was there something in
particular about the definition that was
concerning thank you very much Mike the
right now in our statutes on the
education funding it does not define
English language learner which is why my
concern was with people looking other
places for a definition the English
language learner as it's intended in the
school funding is for those who need to
have that increased level of proficiency
in order to bring up their level of
Competency the definition in this rule
which was an addition because the prior
rule had had no death and I did one want
to clarify that I did misspeak and I
looked at the older Rule and I saw that
that particular definition was new so I
apologize for that no thank you I
appreciate this it's complex but in
English English learner could be
somebody who is absolutely fluent in
English far better than all their peers
but who also fluently speaks Mandarin at
home and So within that definition it
wouldn't be a need for additional
Educational Funding it simply reflects
you know those unique unique benefits or
challenges that a student may have in
their needs I just wanted to make sure
that we had on record that this was not
in any ways intended to change the
education for funding formulation and
that um it does not sort of dilute those
resources no and looking at title III
where that funding would be English
learner is not defined and there doesn't
seem to be any sort of
um
further clarification or saying that
a definition would change the funding
for that I don't know I'm I'm not an
attorney so I don't know how to speak
clearly on that but
do I understand you correctly to say
that an important element of our
educational
funding formula is totally undefined
no
I don't think so
you just said there's no definition of
English language learning no no there is
in the rule what I'm saying is that
death there is no definition of it that
I could that I could see
um but I was browsing while I was
looking so what I would like to say is
that the
um
the deadline for this is August 18th the
meeting is August 17th so if
people are not comfortable with the
definition in the rule then I can bring
Senator yeah so again I think you're
right I think it's that the ell is
defined under under title three yeah and
and that's where the qualifications and
that's where we use as a guideline for
our funding formula and this is relative
to teacher certification so again I
don't think it's going to cross over in
any way shape or form as to how it
relates to education funding so I think
would be okay moving forward with this
with any problem having someone who just
went through the education funding
formula the fine-tooth comb I think
we're fine
represent the fellows all right thank
you um since I worked at the Department
of Education for 32 years and I wasn't
involved with the English language
learners but I was involved with the
adequacy aid and also I had
did some you know tangential work with
different Federal funding programs the
the there's a federal funding program
for English language Learners and um
it's not a lot last I knew it's not a
lot of money it might be a couple
million dollars a year and they defined
a couple of years ago they when I was
there they would Define English language
Learners with I think it was four
different levels and one of the levels
is that they are proficient now but they
still get some Services because they may
not particularly things like the student
high school student who is proficient
but still may need some help with
technical language like if they were
applying to college and they get some
occasional help with that so it would be
a good question to ask the Department of
Education is when you're funding
adequacy Aid what what categories of
English language Learners are you using
I mean it may be all of them it may be
the first two or three levels that would
be a good question I don't think it has
any impact on what the the licensing
okay
representative lamb um thank you with
all this clarification I'm very happy to
know that we're not throwing a larger
net over this I'm not sure if there's
more discussion but if there isn't I I'd
be willing to move to that we approve
second
okay
thank you
okay we have a motion to approve and say
a second is there any further discussion
comments questions
okay those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much
and everyone taking some consent was
HHS evaluation and treatment of income
yes it was 20 23 100.
um
and I'm not sure what the what the issue
was representative lamb uh thank you um
on page eight of the packet page three
of the final proposal there was the note
um to the agency about those who can
prescribe Medical Services supplies or
equipment this is something we dealt
with in our committee a lot about all
the different all the different
abilities to prescribe
um and I think that it might be helpful
to amend this language to say Medical
Services supplies or equipment that are
not covered by Medicaid or which are
prescribed by a licensed Healthcare
practitioner in accordance with state
law something like that so that we
include aprns we include podiatrists we
include everybody who has licensing
Authority because we have people who are
not included under the definition of
position
valenzola I don't even know where you
are because I don't have a page eight
I'm sorry I think that that was fixed in
the conditional approval
it was yeah additional approval is not
posted but I do remember I made that
comment and I thought when I reviewed
the conditional approval that it had
been rectified if we don't have the
conditional approval I'm trying to find
we approve it uh
well it should be representatively on
what um could you give me like the point
zero whatever uh yes one moment it is
page three of the final proposal I just
know that when we're scanning through it
gets to be a little harder it is
um
it's right above there we adopt with
Amendment four yes I four six fifty four
zero
what I'm sorry
Okay so
um again I'm sorry I didn't introduce
myself Nicole valenzola rules
coordinator Department of Health and
Human Services does the version you have
representative Leon say medical
professional at the end instead of
physician it does not where that was
admitted okay
we do have the conditional approval as
part of the packet and now the packet I
have does have that
you just scroll past the the final
proposal and there's a conditional
approach I see that now I'm sorry that
was really confusing to have the
conditional approval in with the final
proposal maybe it's my newness but I
apologize and retract any concern okay
in that case you wish to move to approve
yes so moved back again
okay seconded by the committee
okay seeing none those in favor
aye opposed
thank you very much for explaining that
and uh we'll try and read things more
carefully
yes uh is there any need for the
continued meeting
not that staff is aware of then let's
not have it
okay